therapy is like dress rehearsal for a
relationship thoughts this was so
interesting to me that like the majority
of people find it attractive for people
who work on themselves but a very small
number felt comfortable
um you know revealing that type of
information so hopefully we can bridge
the gap because also it is kind of like
all joking aside it's not what you say
always it's how you say it like hi I'm
Ross I'm in therapy that's funny but it
might come off a little you know
intimidating to someone but if you were
talking and at some point in the
conversation you were like you know what
I do work hard on myself because that's
the journey
um so sexy totally sexy like the you
know what's you know who's not sexy the
one who's like I'm great as I am and I
don't need to change yeah